we've got a first proper trailer out for  she-hulk uh normally i do reactions i  didn't have the time i was buried in  other stuff but uh i will give my  thoughts i've been really looking  forward to this i love she-hulk i love  this run of she-hulk they're largely  basing it on as well where she's a  lawyer i think tatiana muslin is a great  pick i love the vibe in the sense of the  character that we get from this but  oh wow  those effects are rough  that's like eric bonna's hulk rough  and i know some people are being like  well maybe it'll be better by the time  it comes out like i  they've got three months left and this  isn't like the redo of sonic the  hedgehog where like it's gonna look  cartoonish so you can cut a few quarters  like it's supposed to look realistic  and it looks  real bad  oh  i'm nervous now